[Music]
the thing we should do with people who
create art that have done terrible
things well if you found out as a head
of Johnson & Johnson was a serial rapist
that everybody at Johnson and Johnson
knew one way or another
would you still buy that baby powder
sorry your heroes are going away when
there are more important things to do
okay sorry bummer for you Wayne the
construct of society the raping and
killing of women there's a channel
called ID it's devoted to 24 hours a day
of sexualizing murder victims okay stop
it stop it stop it stop it that's my
message just knock it off when you don't
get to like Woody Allen oh what a big
huge loss for you I'm sure that compares
to the girl who's just been raped that
now feels like she wants to hang herself
from her balcony right because that
really bounces out
so when people bitch about that sorry
bummer for you you don't watch Birth of
a Nation do you probably not because you
know it's racist so in time these people
will be looked at like that my job and
others jobs at work in kind of what I'm
doing is to put an asterisk next to
these assholes names for all time and if
people want to cry about not getting to
like somebody they liked on their kids
well get a fucking bigger problem it's
not that complicated people really not
it's really not that's easy
read a different book I I have so many
people fighting me because they want to
stay in the system the system benefits a
point zero zero zero one percent my
ultimate goal is smashing the 99 in the
1% that's what I'm here for and I'm here
to do that through thought and raising
women up and yes in in children of God
the cult I was born into again it some
was like oh they make a big deal of the
cult my I would be talking about Ohio of
that
in my life that just was not but that's
a cult too and I think you all know it
that's the thing no I go it's so weird
how you grew up I think it's weird how
you live
I think it's tragic because like 10%
because there's a lot of free minds
they're out there for sure but we have
to be vigilant what if those 10% of the
world that you look at is the weirdos in
the fringe people what if it's you guys
you know like just like how African
Americans have been saying I remember
hearing about it reading about it when I
was 13 you know that they get killed
when they get pulled over by cops and
that would be like us saying maybe
because someone said that to me in
Germany recently I said this is like
kind of what a woman experiences and he
said maybe waving his hand I thought we
have like a trillion a trillion phd's
and me a woman why because we're in her
skin and you know what's sad is because
when you get sold as an idea the other
side thinks that's what you are so they
were everybody's responding to us
primarily as an idea that sold stumps
for imagery you know Adam Sandler movies
where you have selma hayek Jessica Biel
Kate Beckinsale these accomplished women
with Adam Sandler or a slovenly slob
whose shtick is wearing dirty pants and
and basically having a 2.2 IQ but the
message they send out as you deserve and
that directly with all those young boys
watching leads to the idea but I deserve
the know you actually deserve a complex
woman but only if you two can match that
during World War two each studio had
served their rank they served in the
military
the rank was ministers of propaganda and
they came to them after the war and they
said holy crap women are out in the
kitchen why get back in and that's when
we started seeing Doris Day like
overdrive vacuuming everything he is
once we put video with sound images
sound really if taking a fast if you
notice how fast the destruction of the
world is gone I know tying things the
other people go it can't be can't be
responsible for all that actually it can
it really
really can't there's that two-year-old
on Facebook that video that went around
he's punching along with rocky too and
everyone's because Matt kid no little
Timmy there's just been stolen you've
just stolen what he is and when you're
talking about also you're telling you
what a man is especially telling you
what a white man is and especially
you're telling him how to feel why are
sports so popular in a stupid country
and Jeff why because here that's how men
are the only time traditionally they're
allowed to have an expression of energy
or a release of energy unfortunately
it's in anger and aggression but I it's
a real Western societal interest a real
American problem worse than any other
place I've but I've been a lot of places
and I think when you come from the land
more time behind it right America keeps
going we're so young no we're not white
people are young to it yet dummies we're
just not young you just renamed it you
know what they did in the 20s I thought
this was the height of American hubris
they gave Native American citizenship
they have Indians citizenship and call
them me you know anybody like that's the
mentality we're dealing with and they
fight it on every level they fight I
don't want the Redskins logo off this I
want shut up shut up when your sports
team is sad now you know the traditional
shaming thing what have we done like
since Esther Bryan come on I mean like
since you know I don't know someone
called Mary in the Bible it did the same
thing to me that they did to Mary every
interview is what a man is so I
understood the detail the funneling and
the system of how we sell ideas to
people but we have to understand it's
not just the media it was like how my
family treated me based on coverage
because they're wrestling with they kind
of know me but they think they know me
more from what they see in the media
because that's what they see same with
any man or woman that I've ever been
with anything it friends every it
affected everything it was but the
prison wasn't mine I know that's the
whole thing
unless you're actually
those bars aren't there but we think
they are as you know I was on Stephen
Colbert last night and he said we were
talking about I was wearing a hoodie he
said I wish I could wear that I have to
wear this suit
because I was saying I hate suits I feel
like whenever I wear them and I was
thinking maybe men are cranky because of
this but is your like a t-rex your hands
are like you can't move it's not fun
right it's uncomfortable and men don't
like to be uncomfortable they don't like
itchy things understandably so that suit
paradigms stupid and I said well what
would happen to you if you didn't wear a
suit and he'd say I have two words it
just for as long as I'm like but why and
he actually says at the end we were
talking about it after but you know one
camera cut anything like kind of one
yeah why do I have to were sooo who says
who made that rule who cares
they also made the rule that it was
indiscriminate and okay to rape and
sexually assault in Hollywood it's also
time to stop that and the world run-on
sentence